[Music]
and next up
we have max kuhn
[Applause]
hi thanks for coming so uh
probably maybe to nobody's surprise i'm
gonna talk about model tuning
again um so uh my job within the teddy
bears group is to work on
um kind of all types of modeling and how
we can do that
in a more tidy way the place is stored
for us
oh sorry
thanks uh the place for us to start
normally would be um
with uh more predictive models but tiny
models infrastructures not really
constrained to do
just that we want to work on inferential
models and descriptive models and all
sorts of other things
some of these models need what we call
parameter tuning and that's what i'm
going to talk about today
in this new package we have called tune
so most of our tiny models packages we
tend in the tidy burst we don't tend to
write like one huge package that does
all the things in it so we tend to write
packages that are interconnected with
each other
and so in doing so before i can show you
what tune does i have to show you what a
few other packages
inside tiny models and how they work and
how they feed into tune
so uh if you've never seen teddy models
before
uh we're gonna start with what i like to
call the new iris data
which is the ames housing data it's
basically we have sale prices on houses
in ames iowa
that's what's shown here we have data in
different neighborhoods
and then we have all these features of
houses like their general living area
what type of building it is
and that kind of thing so the goal here
would be to predict
what the sale price is of a house based
on the characteristics of its data set
like the you know the other aspects of
the house
so let's say we were going to
pre-process our data using recipes
so recipes if you've never seen it is a
package that is really good at doing
feature engineering
and pre-processing every data before you
put it in the model and it follows this
sort of
this analogy of like baking a cake or
making something to eat
so you know in a recipe the first thing
you start with when you look at a recipe
is here are the ingredients into the
recipe
so if we load the tidy models package
that loads most of our sort of
individual packages so it's like a meta
package and we can learn the ames
housing data and create the data
so the initial recipe here all it really
does is says you know the ingredients
into our recipe is we have a column
called sale price
that's our outcome and then i just
picked a couple predictors here to look
at
that are in this data set and the recipe
doesn't really do anything at this point
it's just you know beginning to say
here's a list of the like the
specification of the things we want to
do
and the way recipes works is it's kind
of like deep play or gg plot
where you can just keep layering in
things that you want to do to the data
in the order in which you want to do
them
so sale price is very much right skewed
along with a couple other variables
so you can add a step to your recipe
that it says log in the data
you can use basic d plier selectors
including like ends with and things like
that and you can tell it
what base to use a neighborhood
that i highlighted in that map has some
interesting characteristics where there
are a few neighborhoods with only a
handful of
observations in the data set so what
happens sometimes is when you have a
variable that is uh
very unbalanced in its frequency if you
like resample the data or so i want to
make dummy variables it's very often you
get some columns that have like all
zeros and dummy variable column
so we have a step called step other that
what it can do is based on a frequency
cut off that you
use for example the one here you can say
anything that has less than five percent
of the training set in this neighborhood
let's dump that into another category
category called other and then redefine
our factor levels for
that variable to have other in it
instead of the original levels
so that's something you can do you can
make dummy variables
you see there's like a recipe selector
here that that will select all the
character or all the factor variables
and then based on that you can add a few
more things we know from this data set
that there's a linear effect between the
general living area of a house and its
sale price both on log scale
but we've noticed over time that
different building types have different
slopes
so it's an interaction effect so you can
specify interactions
you can also include splines so if you
do a plot of sale price versus longitude
or latitude
you see these really wavy type
relationships between these two
variables and
instead of modeling these predictors in
a linear way you could use a natural
spline so step n s
to replace the original let's say
latitude predictor with
a basis expansion like basically a
couple of non-linear terms
that represent that data and that allows
that
variable to be predicted or modeled in a
non-linear way
so if you ever use like gm smooth
chances are depending on the size of
your data you've used a spline to like
figure out what that non-linear
relationship is
so what you would do with this recipe is
you would apply these steps
in a separate function call you would
apply these steps to your training set
it would do all these operations in
sequence and that would give you like a
ready-made data set that you could then
put into a model
so in terms of modeling oh and one other
thing here is
i chose just based on looking the data
to use five degrees of freedom for the
spline so lower degrees of freedom means
it's less smooth like linear
and higher degrees of freedom allow it
to be more potentially smooth
all right so you might think about using
the parset package to do modeling and if
you've never seen that before it's
very similar recipes in that you make a
specification of what you want to do
before you actually do it
so let's say we just want to fit some
type of linear regression model
like numeric outcome we know we're going
to have slopes and intercepts that's
like the structure of our model
so in parts we have these functions that
delineate like you know you want to do
this type of structure like k-nearest
neighbors
or linear regression or like a neural
network so first you state what type of
model you want to have
which is not really terribly descriptive
as you can see when we print it out
and then you state the engine so the
engine is basically what implementation
do you want to use
so you might use an implementation that
you know does basic analysis to estimate
your parameters or
like a robust regression and so on so
you have a lot of options
i'm going to choose glimnit here which
is like a regularized regression model
but you could have used lm or stan or
kiris or all the things we have
implemented
and so now you've been a little more
specific saying we want to fit this
structure this model
but use this estimation to estimate
parameters
and so i mentioned glimnic does
regularize regression so there are also
some other parameters that we probably
should specify for glimnets
for example the amount of regularization
in this value called penalty
this is a fairly high amount of
regularization and then
what glimnet can do is it could fit two
different types of regularization
it could fit the lasso model which is
like l1 regularization
or it could do ridge regression which is
like l2 regularization
and the cool thing about it is you can
choose a mixture of these things
so if you're not sure whether you should
be doing the lasso ridge regression
you could try a mixture of the two to
see if like you know that works better
for you than just purely one or the
other
so in this call you know i picked you
know a fairly high amount of
regularization
and about a 50 50 mixture of lasso and
um
ridge aggression and you can see when i
print it out it's there
but how do i know like i have all these
special numbers right like five degrees
of freedom
a penalty value of 0.1 and so on so you
might say like oh he must have done a
lot of analysis for this but
basically i can't look at those numbers
and say that's a great model so the
thing about this
is we need to tune these values like if
you want to optimize our model
performance
and we don't know what these values are
and there's no like analytical function
that says plug your x's and y
in and therefore it spits out a value of
whatever for penalty
so we have to do something to find
reasonable values of these parameters
when we can't directly estimate them and
that's called model tuning
i'm going to show you the tuned package
in just a second we have at least two
ways of doing
that model tuning and what we're going
to do is we're going to figure out ways
of tagging
like which parameters do i want to
optimize let's say i only want to
optimize mixture and keep everything
else the same
so how would we tell the tune package
which actual parameters that we should
optimize okay
so we're going to do that in a second um
so i've been at our studio for like
three years i've been thinking about
this particular problem for like
20 years and so when i started working
on parsnip and recipes
you know i've been putting a lot of
thought about okay how is this going to
feed into the
the packages like tune that come later
in the pipe um
and so i was trying to figure out a way
to summarize that that this audience
would understand maybe at least you know
some percentage of this audience would
get
and this is what i came up with
so if you've ever listened to not so
standard deviations you'll know that uh
hillary if you're here
sorry um but you know a lot of really
intense conversations about coffee
and uh that's how i've been thinking
about this particular package
so okay so here's let's say we load the
tune package but that'll be included in
tiny models
these are just the recipe and model
objects that i just showed you
and so what we want to do is we want to
say which of these parameters do you
want to optimize in some way to find
good performance measurements
so what we're going to do is we're going
to substitute these actual values in
with a function call called tune and
this function call doesn't actually do
anything
it just returns an expression that says
tune
maybe not as happy as i just did it but
the point is
um if you've ever used recipes or
parsnip the thing is when you create
your recipe or you create your parsnip
model object it doesn't automatically
just go ahead and fit those things
so we capture all these expressions and
values so we can add in a function value
there because we haven't actually
evaluated any of these arguments
so if we wanted to say which variables
we're going to tune
we can actually instead of putting a 5
in here put this value in
and we'll do it for this one and this
one we can have actually other values
that we keep constant if we like them
um but then when we feed this into this
sort of machinery of tune
it would understand um which ones we
should look at
and we've interlaced everything between
recipes and parsnip and those other
packaged all dials
where we've used like a common
nomenclature for everything so as you'll
see in a little bit
there's a lot of like really good
defaults of everything
so if you don't know like what range of
penalty you should use or what you
should be doing
we have a lot of fairly safe choices
that you can use
to automate the selection of like what
grid you should use and what values and
ranges
so these things all sort of work
together and if you want to specify as
much as possible you can do that
but if like you just want to let the
machine figure it out or if you feel
like oh i don't know what i should do
our reasonable defaults are there to
sort of do that for you
so one thing about this is we're giving
longitude and latitude the same amount
of like smoothness or or wiggliness in
the model and we might want to like
separate those out maybe longitude wants
a little bit of smoothing and
and the other variable wants a lot of
smoothing so what we might do is we
might say
well let's create two different calls
and then we've given them
separate identifiability
but the problem with this is when tune
parses this it sees that there are two
parameters called degrees of freedom
that you're tuning and it doesn't have a
really good sense of like well how do i
distinguish one from the other
so one thing you can do whether you have
this prop or not is you can sort of
annotate the names of these parameters
you can
like if you want to recognize them later
and type something in that your boss
will recognize if you show them some
plots
you can add some id fields here so the
one argument to tune is basically an
optional character string
that this is how that particular
parameter will be identified in plots
and things like that
and it also lets you differentiate what
this degree of freedom parameter is from
this one
and so sometimes you would need to do
this but other times you might just do
it
because you want to use a name that like
makes a lot of sense for you
so now we define what we want to do
there's a couple different ways we can
optimize these parameters and the most
like standard old-school way of doing it
which i think works really well
is use grid search and in grid search
the ingredients of that is you need to
have like some specification of like
what you want to do so you're modeling
your recipe
and then you also need to have or at
least we prescribe you to have
some specification or some object that
dictates how you want to resample the
data
so what we don't want to do is we just
don't want to take our our data set
build a model with these parameters and
just reproduce the data set
so whether it's like a separate single
validation set or whether you do
bootstrapping or 10-fold
a sort of required ingredient that we
don't really have a good default for
deliberately is some resampling
specification
optionally you can define a pre-existing
grid of candidates that you
are in particular interested in
investigating but if you don't we'll
make some for you
and another thing we can do for you but
you can specify is you know whether you
want to optimize
i don't know median absolute error or
root mean squared error so we have
defaults for these if you don't want to
go there
so what we're going to do is we're just
really going to specify these two things
for resampling we're going to use the r
sample package there's enough data here
where 10 fold val cross validation will
be fine the defaults here give you 10
fold and that's
in this object
so our tuning parameters inside this
function start with
tune under bar so tune grid does grid
search and then if you look at the
arguments that here's our recipe and our
model
again these are the versions of that
that have the the placeholder in there
for tune
here's the resamplings uh resampling
object that we need to specify
and then i wouldn't need to do this but
i i just said you know give me 10
tuning parameter values like
combinations of those four parameters
to try based on what you know about
these parameters
and ranges that seem to be applicable so
again you can define those things but
we've set most of these things up for
you
and when you run that you get this kind
of intimidating object looking
back at you the first two columns here
were already in the 10-fold object so
that's what happens when you create a
r-sample resampling object
but depending on the options you choose
you get at least two columns with that
one's called dot metrics and one's
called dot notes you can see they're
list columns with a bunch of tables
embedded in them
so this has all like the arma c values
and r squared values across all the
the 10 models that we wanted to evaluate
and then that's for fold one
here's what the results would be for
fold three and so on and so
what we would want to do is if we want
to get that data and plot it and
investigate it
we would want to do some like d plier
tidy r on nest
stuff to make that happen um rather than
like putting you through that and having
to write that every time we've written
like a bunch of high level accessory
functions
so you can just say what you want to get
and not have to worry about like looking
up how tidy art works and things like
that
so some of them not all of them would
include things like collect my metrics
so take all these tables that are nested
and put them back into a format that i
would like
and so what this does is and let's look
at the first four rows of that
is it gives you the tuning parameter
values that you looked at
so for example the first model used
the first candidate set use these four
values and its arma c value is
in log 10 units is 0.0796
the r squared is almost about 80 and
then we have the second set of um
the second combination of tuning
parameters here and so on
so you might want to take these and sort
them or plot them
um you know sometimes people just you
know they're in a hurry they're trying
out a bunch of different things
they might say just give me the
numerically best one so
let's say give me the one with the
smallest root mean squared error and so
we have functions like show best
which says you know for this object give
me the one with the best arma c
there's another one called select best
which actually just returns the
parameter values
you can select on like the three or the
one standard error rule or other methods
for doing that too so there's a lot that
we're not going into the second
excuse me there's an auto plot method
that i'm fairly dissatisfied with
um so this can only get better um right
now it shows the marginal relationships
so if i plot the latitude degrees of
freedom against let's say r squared
you can see it's like really increasing
and then tanks out here well the reason
it tanks out here is not because
it didn't want that much smoothing it's
because
the penalty value associated with that
particular combination was really high
and that model didn't work so well so
what we need is we need a measure
better visualization tool that could
like represent what's going on here in a
way that people can look at things
um if you've ever seen the shiny sand
package i've always wanted to create
something like that
so my my thought would be you know if
anybody wants to do that
like you know on the plane ride home or
something i'm not gonna
you know reject it um but an idea would
you be where you have your grid
object and run like a shiny tune
function on it and it would open up
a shiny app that would let you maybe do
some interactive investigation of these
things so i'm hoping that's where we go
it's not very hard to do it's just a
matter of like one more thing on the
list of things we want to do here
um so there's some auto plot methods
they'll get better
um so let's say you want to use the
numerically best results like just give
me the one with the
root means grader that's lowest how
would i weave that back into the
the original model objects and retrain
so what you would do is you would let's
say select
the best and that would return
this table of results would like to a
very little amount of regularization
it's about a 50-50 mixture of lasso and
ridge regression
it liked a lot of non-linearity in the
latitude and longitude data
and so um you know so if you're fine
with that what you can do is you can
splice those values back into your
recipe
and into your model object and so we
have these finalized
functions that if you give it the recipe
that has the placeholders for the
parameters
and give it the best parameters it just
splices them back in
as if you would specify them to begin
with so if you do that with the model
and you print the model out remember
before it said like point one and .05
now here are the actual values to you
know whatever precision we have
that it thinks are best and then you can
just do the regular tiny model stuff and
refit this model
and get to the place that you want to
get to
so just some notes about that there's
these things called space filling
designs and statistics so these work
really really well
so it's easy for us to come up with good
and pretty effective
default grids for you using this type of
model
um there might be errors and warnings
and so in carrot and a lot of other
modeling functions like you across
resampling you might fit like
200 models and maybe one of those models
gives like
five warnings and so then when carrot's
done running it says you know you had 2
000 warnings
type warnings to see the first 50 and
you're like huh right and so there's no
way to like trace that back to oh that
was model 7 on resample number three
right so what we do is we we catch
everything as we go so if a model or
recipe that fails
it doesn't stop anything from computing
then we capture all those rest
or those warnings and errors as they go
and we can associate them back to
specific things
where you can go back and trace and see
if like oops i just made a mistake or
there's some weird thing in the data
so that that dot notes column is a
tibble
that basically has all that information
in it um the verbose mode in this i
i don't have the space to show it but
it's i'm really like i use cli
and so i think it's i think it's kind of
cool um
there's a bunch of options so if you
want to save the out of sample
predictions you want to save the model
for each folder the recipe you can do
that
and show it here there's options for
like all sorts of grid stuff and
performance metrics there's a lot i just
sort of glossed over
um brian lewis gave a great talk
yesterday about 4-h and how to use that
for parallel processing so we use that
here again
so whether you're doing like you know
mpi or you want to do multi-core linux
or if you're on windows you have to use
do parallel we have many many
options here to do parallel processing
processing which gives you a lot of
speed ups in what you're doing
and i don't have time to time workflows
but workflows is a another package we
have where you can sort of bind together
recipes and models and some other stuff
together and they're one they're in one
object and this all works with that
so it was grid search i have like a
minute so one thing that we did
implement
is you know i'm not sure if it's like
the best choice here
for the types of models that non-deep
learning models we fit
but you know iterative search especially
during basic optimization is a big thing
it's not really that hard to implement
and so what we have is you would start
off with like a small number
of perimeter values and i can feed in
the ones i just generated
and basically what bayesian optimization
does is it takes those initial 20 points
it predicts a candidate set of values of
tuning parameter values it thinks would
be best to try next
and you can see after the first 10 it
predicts that
you should try these it resamples them
the performance is slightly worse than
the
original and it just keeps going until
either you run out of iterations or it
doesn't see improvement after a while
this works pretty well um its auto plot
method doesn't stink
so you know here's the initial set one
of them really did poorly
one of them failed so you see a little
gap here so you can see
over time or iterations it's it's
staying around the current optimum that
we had and maybe if it went further i
might be able to get a big boost
but um that's the results
it's almost on crayon it's been like
kind of rejected like four times for
little things
so i'm hoping fifth time's a charm um if
you want to learn more is packaged on
site here the training notes from uh
this week and we're working on our tidy
models book
so that'll be in our repo probably in
the next uh the beginning of it
in the next few weeks so keep an eye out
for that thanks
[Applause]
all right we got time for one question
uh does tidy models mark the end of
carrot or are there any plans
for eg carrot ii i'm gonna get this like
tattooed on my arm
uh no karen's not going anywhere i mean
it's not i swear to god it's not cause
everybody asked me this question and i'm
like it's not really
um it's i mean it's not like feature
complete i'm keeping up with it making
sure everything still works
i'm putting most of our development
effort into tidying models um carrots 15
years old
so something that's like 15 years old
it's hard to make a lot of big
feature changes too so it's not going
away i wouldn't expect
huge and like changes or new features in
it but it's
it's doing pretty well as it is so no
worries there for people
all right we'll actually do one more uh
what about proper support for time
series forecasting and tidy models
that's a great question um so i would
think we want to do that
we tend to prioritize what we implement
by things either we have like a huge
increase in interest in or things we
know a lot about and i'm not really a
time series guy
we we want to do this but it's a little
bit lower priority because
the stuff that ron hyman's rob hyman is
doing is so good that
we figure like you're not left with
nothing right now if you want to use
teddy burst type stuff with time
series so i think we'd like to you know
use some of what he's doing there but
you already have something so i think
for the time being
unless somebody wants to implement and
put in a pr or something like that we're
going to work on things that just don't
exist right now before we get to those
things
thanks so much thank you